si tiene hepatitis a su hígado está
inflamado porque ha sido infectado ya
sea con el virus de la hepatitis a o con
el virus de la hepatitis b
su hígado es un órgano suave flexible
que realiza muchas funciones importantes
las partes funcionales de su hígado son
llamadas lóbulos hepáticos sus lóbulos
hepáticos filtran toda la sangre de su
cuerpo
a medida que la sangre pasa a través de
sus lóbulos hepáticos descomponen
sustancias dañinas
remueven bacterias y los glóbulos rojos
gastados
y forman factores de coagulación que
controlan el sangrado
después de una comida su hígado almacena
nutrientes para proveer a su cuerpo con
energía cuando la necesita su hígado
también produce una sustancia llamada
bilis su vesícula almacena bilis y la
libera a su intestino delgado para
ayudar a digerir grasas en los alimentos
que come
si tiene hepatitis o el virus ingresó a
su cuerpo cuando fue expuesto a materia
fecal de una persona infectada con el
virus usted puede estar expuesto al
virus por comer alimentos contaminados o
beber agua contaminada contacto con
heces infectadas como al cambiar un
pañal o tener sexo sin protección con
una persona infectada con el virus si
usted tiene hepatitis ve el virus
ingreso a su cuerpo cuando usted estuvo
expuesto a la sangre u otros fluidos
corporales de una persona infectada con
el virus esto podría ocurrir a raíz de
compartir una jeringa de medicamento con
una persona infectada otros modos en que
usted puede estar expuesto al virus
incluyen tener sexo con alguien
infectado con el virus compartir
artículos de higiene personal como
rasuradoras o cepillos de dientes
utilizados por una persona infectada
contacto directo con la sangre o fluidos
corporales de una persona infectada o
cuando una madre lo pasa a un bebé
durante el nacimiento
cuando el virus de la hepatitis ingresa
a su hígado invade sus células hepáticas
y hace copias de sí mismo
en respuesta su cuerpo envía células
inmunes para atacar tanto el virus como
las células hepáticas infectadas con el
virus como resultado estas células
hepáticas se inflaman y mueren
con el tiempo se forma tejido de
cicatriz alrededor de las células
hepáticas infectadas y muertas lo cual
evita que su hígado trabaje de forma
apropiada si tiene una infección de
hepatitis b crónica su hígado contiene
una gran cantidad de tejido de cicatriz
llamado cirrosis lo que limita el flujo
sanguíneo y resulta en encogimiento
permanente y endurecimiento de su hígado
si usted tiene hepatitis a su médico no
recetar a ningún tratamiento porque sus
células inmunes eventualmente
encontrarán y destruirán todos los virus
de hepatitis en su cuerpo
si usted padece de hepatitis b su
sistema inmune usualmente eliminará
todos los virus de hepatitis b de su
cuerpo
en algunas personas con hepatitis b
crónica particularmente niños sus
células inmunes no pueden eliminar todos
los virus de la hepatitis b
si tiene hepatitis b crónica y su
sistema inmune no puede deshacerse
completamente del virus su médico puede
recetar un medicamento antiviral
si tiene un caso severo de hepatitis b
crónica su médico puede recomendar una
operación de trasplante de hígado